welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
foss and marvel studios celebrates the
movies
is the name of a three-minute long clip
that's probably gonna make me cry
because not only apparently do we have
new footage from the journals we're
getting a new title for black panther 2
captain marvel 2
other big announcements someone at
marvel studios
decided i needed to begin the day crying
had jokes on him i
already woke up crying a pistol of
stress streams so i'll react to the big
highlights on this
and for all the bigger stuff i'll do
separate videos breaking them down
shopping shop here we
go
i love being with people it's the most
incredible thing in the world what are
you doing oh this is nice
that world man
but the one thing that will never change
we're all part of one
big family
that man next to you he's your brother
that woman over there she's your sister
hire further faster baby that's right
we're all part of one universe
oh yeah
i was there not not at this one but i
was somewhere
we were all somewhere
it can't be over we still have a minute
and a half
so much time left
that's new
okay
oh that means okay so
they're showing this they're showing
that let's show more
looks good
[Music]
show us come on come on show us okay
just a title okay that's fine that's
fine
yep
what no go i more i i gotta no time to
react
date confirmed all right
yeah aquafina i know how you feel this
is what marvel does
they announce one huge thing and before
you even have time to digest it no
here's another huge thing
just like one portal after the next
opening up bringing back someone we've
been missing for years
so black panther wakanda forever i love
that like in this super cut
in the beginning they open up by showing
that man over there is your brother it's
t'challa and killmonger and then in the
infinity war battle of wakanda charge
chadwick bo's been going wakanda forever
and that's setting us up for this
amazing reveal
already some great storytelling just by
the editing of this cut so yeah
obviously
too soon to know exactly what wakanda
forever means but
i think we can just tell that this is
already a beautiful title for this film
it's wakanda's rallying war cry
a chant that can be spoken by any
wakandan i believe in an interview last
week lupita niagara said that ryan
coogler had already figured out
how he's going to be handling the
passing of chadwick boseman in the
absence of t'challa they are not gonna
be recasting t'challa they're not gonna
be doing any kind of cgi trickery to try
to bring him back with effects
and right now it seems like googlers
making a really smart move to make this
a story all about the country and the
people of wakanda as opposed to one
individual in that country a story about
how perhaps
shuri okoye umbaku all these people
dealing with that whole idea of
succession
and that could be a really fun way to
explore power dynamics within a setting
like in christopher nolan's the dark
knight the second movie of that series
it was really
a story about gotham and it was all the
better for it but before we continue
special thanks to extra the world's
largest smart wallet brand for
sponsoring this video they designed the
smartest wallets in the world which you
can track with their solar powered
tracker worldwide whether you
dropped your wallet while on an
international spy mission or you just
left it
in your car your tracker will help you
find it instantly it's voice activated
and solar powered
two hours of sunshine gives it a three
month charge
just download the chippelo app on your
phone and you can ring your wallet from
your phone or you can ring your phone
from your wallet
and it works with google home alexa and
siri just put in my wallet i'm gonna
hide it
[Music]
siri where's my wallet
oh i found it
extra slim profile wallets are awesome
they're made of premium leather and have
rfid protection and you use this little
button to instantly
fan out your cards so no more pawing
through an overstuffed wallet no more
giant lumps in your back pocket
check out the wallets with the link
below and earn an additional discount
with our code
exeter.com new rockstars right now if
you use the discount code rockstars
you'll get an extra five percent off on
top of their 20
off mother's day promotion that's a
total of 25
off any extra products with promo code
rockstars
so some limited new footage for chloe
zhao is the eternals and i gotta say it
looks
like a chloe shower movie it looks like
no mad land a lot of pastoral settings
so on horseback a freaking farmer here
is sama hayek as ajax ajak is kind of
the eternal
spiritual leader apparently she can
communicate with the celestials the
godlike beings of the mcu
the ones who created all of this
including these eternals the ancient
i guess you can call them caretakers of
earth we have a beach with several of
the eternals including
barry kogan as druid on the left then a
shot of several eternals including
camille nanjiani as kingo
liam mchugh as sprite gemma chan as
cersei richard madden that's rob stark
from game of thrones says icarus
who is kind of the tactical leader of
the eternals angelina jolie as
theena she's kind of the military
commander of the eternals and don lee as
gilgamesh
and looking at the background of the
shot it looks like they're in some kind
of um
woodland cult a bunch of people in
overalls and i'll probably have to look
more into this in the breakdown but
there is a
camera crew behind kumail there so is
this bts footage and they're just
showing crewmember
in the shot or it's camille's character
as a bollywood movie star being followed
by some kind of movie crew
i'll go more into that and then just a
bit of dimly lit
action with angelina jolie with her
sword she can form any weapon out of
cosmic energy actually if you go through
a frame by
frame you can see the base of the stored
is still kind of weaving together
i love the look of that and then in
front of the walls of what looks like an
ancient city
they're joined by lauren ridloff as
makari she
is super fast she can use her super
speed to scout planets she can create
sonic booms with their super speed and
she is the first death superhero in the
mcu and as such when she creates sonic
booms with her speed it doesn't affect
her what's interesting is it looks like
the ruins of a crashed
vessel a ship over to the right there so
even though this is an ancient city it
was attacked by some kind of advanced
aircraft and then jimmy chan at cersei
says we're the ones who changed
everything
as is true they have been on the planet
the entire time throughout the mcu
and the reason things are the way they
are is because the eternal said so so
maybe this alternate history that we're
seeing in the mcu
is just because of the eternal's
existence mankind was supposed to go on
a trajectory as we currently are in but
the eternals were that x factor in the
ultimate history of the mcu who
resulted in it being a history filled
with superheroes meaning we're gonna go
back to the origin of the mcu and get
some better terms for
what all these things are including
perhaps mutants and yeah another
announcement we got the marbles that's
going to be the name of captain marvel
2. which makes sense we have lots of
captain marvel related people who are
going to be in this movie including brie
larson coming back as carol danvers as
well as monica rambo coming back from
one division last time we saw her she's
gonna be up with the scrolls in space so
maybe the secret of asian series on
disney plus will do a lot to set up this
movie along with miss marvel because
iman valani is coming back from miss
marvel in this show as
miss marvel comic con nia de costa will
be directing this one
and we got some confirmation that
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 will
release
in may 2023 i've been ready for that
movie for four years
but two years will be enough time to
find that missing easter egg in
guardians of the galaxy volume one and
we end on just again a logo for the
fantastic four movie we don't know when
this is coming hopefully by the end of
2023
however nothing announced so far for
blade or for captain america four i'm
sure all of that is coming
uh look there's a lot in this i want to
take some time to break it all down in
separate videos so stay tuned on the
channel there's gonna be a lot to talk
about
so be sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos
follow new rockstars on social media
check out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com and also be sure
to stick around because in addition to
talking about this stuff we got loki
coming up in the pipeline for which
we'll be doing after shows and
breakdowns of all of that
it's a great time to be a nerd thank you
for crying with me this morning
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you